[Music]
last week Rafferty I tweeted out what is
a despicable disgusting vile video
attacking the First Lady Melania Trump
as a stripper we're not going to show a
lot but here's a part of it
[Music]
the left's never-ending in recent
violence the first lady didn't stop
there last Friday one of the co-hosts of
the views suggesting that the first lady
may have been president Trump's mistress
these are vile attacks watch this she's
not concerned with his mistresses
because she was one of them there's no
one to the first lady told ABC that she
was one of the most bullied people
because it's true
here with reaction senior adviser to
Donald J Trump for president president
Trump's daughter-in-law Laura Trump I
know Melania I've had a chance to really
meet her English is our fifth language
an amazing background life career we saw
the incredible trip she just took the
dignity the class she has if you're not
a Democrat the Democrats are silent okay
I want to go after Judge Cavanaugh
defense stormy yeah
but not a Vanka when the C word is used
not you when you're attacked and the
first lady the attacks on her I can't
imagine that happening to Michelle Obama
ever or Hillary Clinton even this
supposed party of women Sean is as you
said completely silent here I'm waiting
for anyone to speak up against this on
the Democrat side and we have heard
absolute crickets from them it's
disgusting and sadly it's not that
shocking anymore because we know that
there is no low to low for the left for
the media for Hollywood when it comes to
the President to the first lady and to
the entire first family and I don't care
what side of the political aisle you're
on the First Lady of the United States
deserves respect this is disgusting and
it should be condemned by everyone well
I don't hear any F P calls for any FBI
investigations
keith Ellison you know like they did
Judge Cavanaugh and some of those
allegations were so over the top though
it was patently absurd I don't see them
ever defending Melania Trump ever yes
where's Hillary where's Pelosi was
Feinstein wandered across the board
and and and you think about how
differently this would have been treated
if this were our previous first lady
again I think it is horrible it doesn't
matter who you voted for whether or not
you are democrat or republican this is
disgusting and it absolutely should be
condemned by everyone I know you're
working on 2020 but an interesting
phenomenon is happening we do have this
important election things seem to have
shifted dramatically especially in the
Senate races
I'm worried more about the house I hope
people pay very close attention if they
vote for a congressman they're voting
for Pelosi vote for the Senate right
well you see real trouble for Claire
McCaskill who's been exposed bredesen
has been exposed Dean Heller is doing
better in Nevada
Kristin's cinemas collapsing in Arizona
Heidi Heitkamp is collapsing Joe
Donnelly is in trouble what do you say
to people about these House races where
are more concern tonight well the entire
midterm election is so so important and
that's why you've seen the president out
on the road like he's been and I think
he's having a real impact you just
mentioned all these races Sean this is
making an impact with people across the
country who were voting in the midterm
elections and again oftentimes the
midterms are not as exciting for people
to get out and vote in often times
people stay home you cannot stay home on
November 6th early voting in North
Carolina starts tomorrow I was there all
day today campaigning with some great
candidates down in North Carolina you've
got to get out you've got a vote early
and you've got to vote for Republicans
their agenda simple impeachment endless
investigation they want it back tax cuts
open borders but don't say it
impeachment don't say it keep Obama care
that's the whole agenda and socialism of
course I mean it's it's crazy what the
Democrats are proposing and I hope
everybody's paying attention because we
have to keep the house and the Senate in
the midterms all right Laura Trump thank
you for being with us and on behalf of
so many we apologized our first lady
deserves so much better and it's sad